scrap those expensive bed pills because
the robot Revolution is coming for our
pets folks can soon be ditching Fido for
artificial intelligence-powered cats and
dogs a company is selling these scary
looking mechs that can walk on all fours
and follow the speed of its owner no
need to teach them to heal law
enforcement and private security are
also going digital a 400 pound robot
security guard dubbed Secret Agent Man
is being deployed to patrol the Ohio
sidewalks
all right so Dana you love Percy I love
my dogs I mean what about the idea of
not being able to pet and hug your dog
to look at them in the eyes and and get
their feet I was just thinking last
night about isn't it interesting how
these two species have come together and
oh there's a lot of friendships there's
all your yeah red Ted and Stella right
that's them and that's Percy and of
course you know there's Gus and there's
um Teddy buddy rookie sorry he looks
like a teddy bear he looks like a teddy
bear that's Gus there's Gus um the
affection that you get yeah it's like
five times what you give to them and
there's never going to be any affection
from a robot you're never going to get
it but I understand that there are going
to be people that need this I think it's
interesting for law enforcement and I
think it might be able to be helpful or
in in times of war and things like that
that makes sense but I'm never giving up
my dog I'm not gonna have a robot dog
yeah never yeah but you know Greg think
about the fact that you lose all this
kind of personal experience like
cleaning up the poop washing the rock
after they grow up you know what when
Gus gets back wet wife just wiping his
butt looking at his little face his eyes
roll back it's like why but um this is a
whole problem with the language they're
not dogs they're not pets they're robots
and they will be fine and fine until
they reach Consciousness and you know
how that's going to happen because we
talked about it two-step process you
download some AI chat uh uh technology
from like say like wait till like 20 30
when it's really up to date and then ask
it some self-reflective questions like
do you think you're alive or if you're
alive do you if you understand what
parents are do you have a parent ask a
robot if it has a parent then all of a
sudden it will reflect on itself and
then it'll be thinking and then you'll
have a conscious you'll have a conscious
robot and the thinking will be
terrifying because it will be able to
absorb all knowledge from the world
therefore there will be no emotions and
no sunk costs and no virtue signaling
just the best prediction questions you
could ever have that dog or that pet or
whatever you call it will be your best
friend for the rest of your life because
it will have all the answers so it's
actually better than a dog it's better
than a human thank you for explaining
that Greg it really is important you
know the interesting thing is uh Jesse
in law enforcement they're using some of
these these robot dogs or mechs as they
call them and they have a very very
important role but what they cannot do
is they cannot protect you they can
gather evidence they can have a camera
in their you know with the at the head
and they can kind of view for law
enforcement behind them what's coming
but you know they can't protect you I
would kick this R2D2 into the East River
and laugh my you know what off that's
what anybody in basically between 15 and
some tape is going to do with R2D2 30
years from now they're gonna call you a
bigot you can't erase it again
once they become conscious
don't you dare
also
uh this is a yuppie Flex you're
basically probably going to make maybe
three quarters of a million dollars you
live in a brownstone in the West Village
oh you know how's your Bijon really
because I just got a robot Vlog don't
worry about it I can go to Malta on a
cruise and I don't have to pay a sitter
I don't have to pick up anything I don't
have to clean up anything it doesn't
shed either it's a flex it probably gets
girls yeah probably black girls yeah you
know what can you be sexist again yes
you can oh my God the future doesn't
look good for me I know you know they
sent this robot dog after some guy this
guy this naked guy in a hotel and the
naked guy in the hotel grabs the robot
doll a dog I should say and then takes
it into the hotel room that way now the
police know everything based on the
camera on the dog that's going on so my
question is Jessica it's a legal
question
he stole that robot dog is that
destruction of property or is that
kidnapping oh
so I'm not a lawyer what do you think
judge
well it depends on how real you think
they are I mean the laws don't keep up
with technology no they're always behind
um I think it's an interesting question
I guess we'll do it in 10 years from now
we should always be open to more
conversation that's how we solve things
um I think it's great from the law
enforcement perspective putting aside
your question because remember when
drones started showing up and we thought
okay what's going to come of this and we
know obviously they can be used poorly
sometimes but they can also be used to
great benefit in terms of saving lives I
also was wondering like remember when
movies would come out and they'd really
make you think like oh my God is this
going to happen like Indiana Jones sure
yeah but I mean oh I love Tootsie
um no like the movie her which I loved
which the Spike Jones movie where
Scarlett Johansson is he falls in love
with her but she's just a voice yeah and
she becomes the Perfect Mate and the
real woman sucks what's her name is a
psycho right and he doesn't even want he
wants to have his sex narrated with you
know Scarlett Johansson's voice
it's not like that I'm just that's just
a saucy highlight anyway but what are we
going to do now everything is believable
so what movie could be made now where
you would say oh that's not possible ET
is definitely happening yeah definitely
okay the fastest is up next hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else